you and I agree it could be Biden Trump
the rematch or it could be Biden some
versus someone else but if it is Biden
Trump uh I saw one poll that said 58 of
Americans would want an alternative to
those two candidates to to our
discussion their combined age in 2024
would be 159. uh Joe would be 82 and and
Trump would be 77. uh and I think that
would be a very very clear emblem to the
dysfunction of our selection process
where it's like wait a minute you have a
country of 300 million people and like
we're choosing between this guy and that
guy and so so 58 of Americans would look
around being like do I have an
alternative Biden's great weakness in my
mind is his age
um I you know I know all the talk about
like oh he's a liberal or you know you
can debate all that stuff policy wise
but I think the biggest thing that the
average person
has an issue with is his age like do I
really want someone who you know my
grandfather is 82 do I really would I
really want my grandfather as the
president United States I think that's a
very relatable concern for lots and lots
and lots of people to my mind the best
again if you're in an objective vacuum
and Donald Trump you know you can keep
Donald Trump from the nomination the
best approach for Republicans if winning
is the goal is to nominate someone who
is generationally you know several
Generations younger than Joe Biden to
say look Joe Biden's policies are old
Joe Biden is old we need a change we
need fresh blood you know we need a
fresh Vision Donald Trump can't really
make that argument right I mean it's
just these couple years younger than
than Joe Biden it's not like Donald
Trump is a policy Visionary you know I I
think he is I think he is simultaneously
the most likely Republican nominee and
out of the major candidates we've talked
about probably the weakest Republican
nominee in that I can see a path that
Biden runs and wins again on a very
similar message which is the like let's
this is a return to normalcy like you
want this guy who's out there pushing
like crazy conspiracy theories or do you
want me who you may not love who you may
think is too old but like I'm not going
to crash the Republic into a mountain I
was on a panel with Chris Christie a
little while ago and Chris said uh a
generic Republican will defeat Joe Biden
and then I said congratulations Chris
but a generic Republican can't win your
nomination
that's exactly right
and so you you wind up so I I think that
Democrats will be looking at each other
saying like are we really gonna run Joe
back uh you know I I like and uh and
then be like well if it's against Trump
he'll he'll win and then if it seems
like a non-trump candidate is emerging
then they'll start freaking out you
mentioned polling uh you know there's a
pull out in New Hampshire last week that
showed that you know a majority of
Democrats don't want Biden to run again
now some of that is because he has come
out and said I don't think New Hampshire
should have the first amendation yeah
they did love that like yeah they're not
I mean these are people who have built
uh a cottage industry around having the
First Nation primary but I do think if
you go and look at polling outside of
New Hampshire there's lots and lots of
people including lots and lots of young
Democrats who don't want Joe Biden to
run again now those polls rarely ask why
right they just say do you do you think
Joe Biden should be the nominee or do
you want Joe Biden be the nominee but
you know my strong sense is that there
is some trepidation about nominating
someone of his age uh to another
four-year term I mean we people went
crazy when Ronald Reagan was Ronald
Reagan was a gonna be a decade younger I
know a spring chicken compared to Joe
right and so
I think you're right I mean I think
they're I think there is a again if
there wasn't if Biden didn't have
control of sort of the reins of the
nominating process which he does in
which you know incumbent presidents
generally do it's not like he's unique
in this but if he didn't have the full
reins of the nominating process is there
Lane where you could run as a sort of
generational change that you know look
Biden did a lot of great things but you
know the future of the democratic party
can't be an 82 year old man who will be
you know in his mid to late 80s by
excuse me by the time he runs for by the
time he's finished in office like that's
that's a case that there is some polling
data at least that suggests there's
interest there again particularly among
younger voters uh younger Democratic
voters so it's one of those things that
I think there's a constituency for it
I'm just not sure there's a candidacy or
a candidate for it yeah in in part
because of what you said before which is
look if you are an up-and-comer you're
not going to ruin your relationship with
the current president and most everyone
of importance in the DNC by thrusting
yourself into this race which is one
reason why I think that Joe's going to
declare for reelection and then everyone
is going to say JoJo he's our guy uh and
get behind and when I say everyone I
mean everyone in the Democratic
establishment is going to say uh JoJo
he's our guy
foreign